twitter's board has decided to sell the
company accepting tesla billionaire elon
musk's offer of 54.20
per share in cash which values the
company at around 44 billion dollars
shares of twitter added to recent gains
and jumped more than five percent on
monday after the social media company
formally accepted the buyout offer
the transaction was unanimously approved
by twitter's board of directors with the
deal expected to close later in 2022
pending shareholder approval
twitter was until recently expected to
decline musk's offer to buy the company
but the board appeared to be more
receptive to musk's acquisition offer in
recent days
especially after the tesla billionaire
revealed in an sec filing last week that
he had secured 46.5 billion dollars in
financing
musk has secured 25.5 billion dollars of
fully committed debt and margin loan
financing for the deal and is providing
an approximately 21 billion equity
commitment according to a press release
earlier this year musk became the
richest person in the world
unseating jeff bezos who held that title
for four years prior
the tesla and spacex chief is worth
268.2 billion dollars
that's over 96 billion dollars more than
bezos ranked second on the
list even after selling billions of
dollars in tesla stock late last year
and owing taxes on the gains from those
sales
musk is estimated to be
117.2 billion dollars richer than on
march 18th 2021
when forbes finalized last year's
billionaires list
musk's first time on the list was 10
years ago with a net worth of 2 billion
but in the last 2 years his net worth
really took off
musk owes his status as the world's
richest person mostly to tesla's soaring
and volatile stock price
the volatility can be partially
attributed to musk's erratic reputation
on twitter
for instance when he challenged russian
president vladimir putin to single
combat after spacex started sending
telecom gear to ukraine
tesla's stock has been criticized by
some analysts and investors and musk
himself
for being priced too high
but shares have continued to climb
gaining another 35 percent in the last
year
this happened despite widespread
automotive chip shortages stricter
regulations of chinese user data that
the company uses for its self-driving
systems
and the recall of hundreds of thousands
of teslas in 2021
musk owns about 21 of the company but
has pledged more than half his stake as
collateral for loans
wall street analysts were largely split
when musk first went public with his
unsolicited offer to buy twitter earlier
this month
some experts predicted that the soap
opera would end with musk acquiring the
company while others remained highly
skeptical and downgraded twitter's stock
amid the uncertainty
the vast majority of analysts maintain a
hold rating on twitter shares as the
market waits to see what happens with
musk's potential takeover
[Music]